ينطلق بعد ساعات حدث تاريخي سعودي عنوانه
متصدر الاخبار والمنصات وكمان ترند وهو
السعوديه النحو الفضاء فاذا الفضاء
السعوديين علي القرني وريان البرناوي
سينطلق في مهمه نحو محطه الفضاء الدوليه
وراح يكون معاهم رائده فضاء امريكيين كمان
على نفس الرحله هذه المهمه هي احدى
مبادرات الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء واللي
انطلقت لتعزيز مكانه السعوديه في مجال
الفضاء وتطوير قدراتها ضمن رؤيه 2030
الليله راح ينطلق صاروخ فالكون 9 اللي
بيحمل مركبه دراغون تو في رحله التنقيب
واستكشاف الفضاء واللي راح تستمر 12 يوم
وسيشارك فيها الفريق السعودي ب 14 تجربه
فضائيه سته منها في الدماغ والجهاز العصبي
واربعه منا في الخلايا المناعيه وتجربه في
الاستمطار وثلاثه تجارب تعليميه توعويه
[موسيقى]
اربعه ثلاثه
اثنين
واحد
[موسيقى]
هذه بخصوص الرحله اما عن رائده الفضاء
فريانا برماوي هي اول رائده فضاء السعوديه
عربيه مسلمه عمرها 33 سنه ومعها بكالوريوس
في علم الهندسه الوراثيه وتطوير وماجستير
في العلوم الطبيه وبتعمل حاليا كمان في
مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي كاخصائيه في
الابحاث المخبريه وكانت نشرت من ساعات
تغريده عن موعد انطلاق الرحله وطلبت من
الناس متابعه التحديثات على حساب الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء وارفقتها بصوره لها
احساسه بالفخر بهذه المهمه اكبر شعور انا
اهم محاور رؤيه 2030 دعم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه للمراه من اهداف الباحثين
والعلماء والمطورين اللي على الارض يجربوا
تجاربهم هذه في الفضاء دوري الان هو اني
امثل المملكه في هذه المهمه العلميه
علامات رحله اي اكس تو وتعد هذه البعثات
الفضائيه هي احدى ثمار هذه الرؤيه ويوصل
طموحنا لعلان السماء
[موسيقى]
اما على الجن فهو اول رائد فضاء سعودي يصل
للمحطه الدوليه ومن مواليد سنه 92 وعنده
بكالوريوس في علوم الطيران من كليه الملك
فيصل الجويه في الرياض وبيعمل مقاتل على
طائرات اف 15 برتبه نقيب طيار في القوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه علي كمان شارك مع
متابعي على تويتر الكثير من التغريدات
المتعلقه بالرحله بس يمكن من اكثر ما
تفاعل مع الناس صوره شنطته اللي ماخذها مع
الفضاء في وسط كل الحماس والاستعدادات
للرحله ما احد جاء على باله رواد الفضاء
ايش بياخدوا في شنطهم وكان كمان شارك مع
الناس مجموعه من التدريبات اللي عملها قبل
ما تنطلق المهمه وكيف استعد لها
اختياري من ضمن برنامج رواد الفضاء
السعودي يعتبر اكبر انجاز لي في حياتي
سامثل الوطني المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
هذه الرحله العلميه وهي مسؤوليه كبيره جدا
نحمل رايه كبيره
وطبعا التفاعل مع علي وريانه كبير جدا
واسمهم وحساباتهم في كل مكان على المنصات
وجالسين بنشوفها في كل تغريده حساباتهم مع
النادي جديده نسبيا والمتابعين عليها
بعشرات الالوف لسه لكنهم بيزيدوا بشكل
كبير لحظه بلحظه والمشاهدات والتفاعل مع
الحسابات واضحه جدا صوره علي اللي تكلمنا
عنها مثلا عليها اكثر من مليون مشاهده
وصوره ريان اللي نزلتها من كم يوم لاخر
يوم لها قبل العزل اللي بيسبق السفر
للفضاء عليها اكثر من مليون و600 الف
مشاهده وعلى فكره حتى الاطفال كان لهم
نصيب من التفاعل ففي طفل اسمه هاشم العلوي
بيقول عن نفسه رائد فضاء المستقبل طلع في
فيديو ووجه نصائح لعلي وريان قبل رحلتهم
سبيس
[موسيقى]
سامسونج
شاركوا فيديو هاشم وشكروه على نصائحه
ووعدوا انهم راح يلتزموا فيها
احنا معانا من مركز كندي للفضاء موقع
انطلاق المهمه مراسل العربيه حسين اهلا
فيك معانا حسين يوم يعني جميل وتاريخي اذا
تحكيلنا الاجواء عندك كيف يبدو وعندك حر
كمان الشمس يبدو قويه
جدا هو يوم تاريخي خطوه عملاقه والاجواء
حماسيه في انتظار في ظل انتظار الرواد لكي
ياتوا بعد ساعه ونصف تقريبا عبر مروحيه
الى هنا الى مركز كندي حيث سيلوحون
لاهاليهم ولاصدقائهم قبل ان يستلمهم فريق
سبيس اكس على الساعه الواحده والربع
لاجراء التحضيرات النهائيه قبل الدخول الى
المركبه الفضائيه ثم الانطلاق باذن الله
تعالى الى الفضاء الخارجي طبعا هذه
الاجواء كما قلنا صحيح هناك حرب لكن هناك
ايضا
نوع من الجو اللطيف اليوم كما اخبرنا
العاملون هنا في وكاله ناسا الصاروخ عندما
سينطلق صار اذا سمحت لي
هو يتكون جسده من مركبه فضائيه دراغون وهي
اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه لنقل البشر الى
المحطه الدوليه الفضائيه عندما ينطلق
الجزء الثاني من الصاروخ وهو صاروخ فالكون
يتكون من قسمين القسم الاكبر يتضمن تسع
محركات عندما يصل الى ارتفاع 80 كيلو مترا
فوق سطح البحر
ويصل الى سرعه صوت مضاعفه الى عشر مرات
سينفصل هذا القسم ليسقط في البحر ثم يبدا
القسم الثاني ذات المحرك الواحد بالعمل
لمده سبع دقائق تقريبا حتى يضع المركبه في
مدار فضائل معين وينفصل هو ايضا بنفسه ثم
تتحرك المركبه تدور حول الارض لتخفف
سرعتها حتى تلتحم بالمحطه الفضائيه وقد
يستغرق ذلك سته عشر ساعه
عندما يصل الرواد علي وريان مع رئيدي
الفضاء الامريكيين الى المحطه سيبداون
باجراء اختبارات عديده 14 اختبارا
يختبرون تاثير الجاذبيه على الاعضاء
البشريه اختبارات علميه اخرى هو برنامج
طموح في الحقيقه يسعى به
حسين اذا تحكيلنا انت ذكرت انه في تحضيرات
سبقت الرحله وانه لسه في تحضيرات لمن
حيوصلوا الان اذا تحكيلنا عن هذه
التحضيرات اللي سبقت والتحضيرات اللي
بتنتظرهم الان
التحذيرات التي سبقت هي التدريبات هي
اجراء
محاكاه للاختبارات التي التي سيقومون بها
اختبارات للصحه الجسديه لرواد الفضاء ايضا
تدريب على كيفيه قياده المركبه عندما تصعد
الى الفضاء كيفيه اجراء المختبرات هناك
محاكاه يقومون بها على سطح الارض عندما
يصلون الى هنا
سيقومون باختبارات اخيره الاستعداد كما
قيل على موقع
الوكاله الهيئه الفضائيه السعوديه هي
انتهت البارحه لسدادات النهائيه ولكن هناك
استعدادات ما قبل الانطلاق سيقومون بها
عندما يستلم فريق سبيس اكس الرواد الاربعه
هي هي استعدادات الروتينيه اخيره اللمسات
الاخيره هذا صح التعبير قبل دخولهم الى
المركبه في الصاروخ ثم باذن الله ينطلقون
الى الفضاء هذا اجراء روتيني طبعا عندما
تحدثنا الى مسؤولين فيها ناس هنا سالناهم
هل يمكن ان يكون هناك تاخير الناس اعطت
ويندوز فتره زمنيه الصاروخ يجب ان ينطلق
على الساعه الخامسه والنصف في توقيت
فلوريدا ولكن اذا تاخر قليلا قد ينطلق على
الساعه التاسعه والنصف بتوقيت فلوريدا
ولكنهم يتوقعون بان يكون اليوم جميل بان
لا يكون هناك اي اضطرار لتاخير هذه الرحله
يتبقون ان تكون مشاكل وتنطلق بخير وسلامه
الى الفضاء واهلهم موجودين حسين صحيح حسين
حيكونوا شايفين اهل ريانه وعلي
صحيح الاهل سياتونا بعد قليل سيكون هنا في
بالقرب من هذا المكان سينتظرون اولادهم
حتى ياتون عندما ياتي الرواد سيلوحون لهم
لكن هناك مسافه اخبرنا الموظفون في
المسافه بسبب